okay by me okay babe eacha boy
psychobabble we're doing mission 3 and
blocking dot take it we make lots of
money okay let's do this Oh mechanics oh
there's a lot of [ __ ] here it's getting
really complicated um labor inbred [ __ ]
I'm like bread I don't know how to make
bread guys stop asking me okay i guess
i'm not going to use that cafe yeah cuz
i don't think it makes bread that's just
like a bread factory here huh my check
real quick nope nope no bread machine up
tourists okay so we're going to we're
going classic entry home classic um put
some trees right here we need some water
yes today [ __ ] and they like deactivate
something slow pain was so much cleaner
okay um [ __ ] [ __ ] mmm we got to start
with the houses and I'm just skipping
two large apartment because it's
basically what we need now maybe a
little too much but will say I will say
okay we got people we have leisure
shipping on a pleasure
everything on top okay yeah um [ __ ] it
imma [ __ ] your city good money is going
down that's because I was working
gotta make these retail shops babies you
just gotta make these retail shops
actually it's all really needed this
mission [ __ ] really oh no too crazy here
mmm consumer yeah too much right here
yeah let me to leave all these guys it's
a more [ __ ] leisure that's what I
need yep my way guys wrong right people
just love leisure and I don't blame them
you know I to like leisure I mean you
better than trees do like leisure again
I labor which means none of [ __ ]
apartments right am I making money Oh f0
labor I'll never get any [ __ ] money
[ __ ] ooh ok [ __ ]
there's big one from violent labor okay
there we go we should have Lavery now ok
we're going up or labor go and make that
money baby make that money back Manny
hmm yes okay this is dara this is dead
of it nothing should be decaying now
Bridget of cated it shut
ok not going it's good it's getting less
red ok we're good everything is just
going up so we're literally just waiting
for the money to stop all up now look at
her go ahead buy something for yourself
I saw but you deserve it you deserve it
ok I want some more money so we gotta
spray this out a little bet you know how
cyan ok that makes a lot of money but
any community I don't have a [ __ ] team a
community greenhouse gas you know get it
wastes consume it I mean Brett I know
how you get Brad as an input makes a lot
of money though strike another retail
shop it let's get justice speed this up
ok now consumers going to low so we'll
have to do this like that baby yeah yeah
yeah yeah baby oh baby when you're not
canticle at us baby I'm getting caught
in the rain baby you like being a
colostomy and getting caught in the
[ __ ] rain yet
yeah okay okay let's see here let's see
here anymore lecture today [ __ ] I think
we're gonna [ __ ] downward spiral now
shut because bad it's not my [ __ ]
fault okay I tried to try to sway things
up a little bit okay I tried to sway
things up there we go there we go how he
losing consumer still I mean like a
million consumers
hmm hope we make it 12 money before we
[ __ ] run out of consumers [ __ ] [ __ ]
no [ __ ] okay good if you like pina
coladas and getting lost in the rain
baby you like pina coladas and getting
lost in the rain yeah yeah let's make
that money baby let's make that money
yeah yeah yeahs get morgan sores yes
perfect my plan is working
[ __ ] I need my laser just a little bit
just I love it to unplug oh good just
got good good now we're making the money
like crazy you know what I'm saying he
was also you got it I'll be back Toby's
about it thanks about osiris respite
niceness video Garcia mmm I see it no
it's not nothing you guys okay I'll take
you know it's like me right